this is a production of cornell
university
great thanks a lot andy as andy
mentioned
today we're going to use the rest of the
seminar period to
take a deep dive into the benefits of
soul carbon
this is a topic that valentina and i
have been deeply interested in
and have been really excited
to talk with you many of you over the
past couple months about this topic
so we'll be sharing some reflections and
hopefully
just bring up some points that gets us
continually thinking about the nuances
and complexities around this topic
we can move to the next slide how
perfect so let's just
first take a look at the current
environment there are a ton
of rapidly growing so carbon credit
markets
out there here i have listed just a
couple
many that you are familiar with but this
list seems to be growing
nearly on a weekly monthly basis and
this is mainly being driven
by many multinational companies making
really ambitious
involuntary carbon neutrality goals for
the next 10
20 30 years and so
some of these goals are so ambitious we
have companies like
microsoft that not only are they looking
to become
carbon negative by 2030 for example
they're looking to
get rid of all their historic emissions
by that date as well
so there really does seem to be an
opportunity for
uh carbon credits and this is where the
extent of the excitement and energy in
this space is really
is really growing and being driven by
from a policy standpoint there are
multiple legislation both at the federal
and the state level that are
looking to bring some sort of clarity
consistency
standardization to carbon credits and
ecosystem
services marketplaces in general one of
the one
of a couple but maybe the most
well-known one is the the growing
climate solutions act
where academics private industry
commodity groups government have all
been on board on
hey there is this need there's this
growing there really is this growing
energy we need to
have some sort of standardization and we
also need pathways
for farmers and ranchers to understand
how to enter these markets
looking at our own home state here
there's a bill coming through
that's looking to establish a carbon
farming tax credit
and that should if any of you have read
that bill it's quite vague
there's a lot to be answered on how
that's being done how that's verified
and really what that's going to look
like
but the space is there and the
conversations are happening
so when we hear groups talking about
building so carbon
generally they're being generally
from a greenhouse gas sequestration
point of view
we also hear many co-benefits rattled
off
most commonly and this is coming from
again this is coming from
policy makers private sector academia
but
talking about co-benefits one of the
ones that we hear most often
is increases in so carbon will increase
yield
or increases in so carbon will save
farmers money on inputs reduce input
costs input needs and input cost
and then also there's also mentions of
increases in so carbon will build some
the so microbial community
and we know many of these are true but
at the same time we also know
that these are going to vary by place
cropping system by approach and
we know there are some complexities
around this and
and um and so that's what we'll do over
the next couple of slides is talk a
little bit
more about those details
so thanks emily so what is the real
potential contribution that soil organic
carbon can
give us in terms of accomplish or
increasing these
co-benefits or ecosystem services when
we're thinking about
fixing carbon to improve or to reduce
co2 in the atmosphere the relationship
is very
straightforward every kilogram of carbon
that we fix in our soil
is a kilogram we remove from the
atmosphere
and we have a lot of tools over there
this map for example here
that is soil reveal made with solarville
is showing
how much carbon can we gain in different
parts of the world
by changing a management practice
so we know exactly how much
is the benefit of increasing carbon in
the different regions
however when we are thinking about these
other co-benefits that are mentioned
the relationship is much more
complicated
and the same amount of carbon can have
completely different meanings
in terms of how it's going to affect
water quality or
food security in different parts of the
world
so we wonder how these co-benefits or
what factors
do control the impact that we might have
by fixing carbon in these co benefits
and what are
the knowledge gaps that that we have to
answer that question
so the main framework for our discussion
today
is this recognizing that solar organic
carbon
plays a key role in the definition of
soil physical
chemical and biological properties that
be all soil health
and and then therefore are going to
determine the capability of the soils to
contribute
to different ecosystem services
and when we go in to see water
the soil properties that are mentioned
or are affected by soil organic carbon
we can here we are listing some examples
but
we heard and we know that increasing
carbon
carbon is going to increase water
infiltration
water holding capacity nutrient
availability
and biological activity of the soil
however when we try to
figure out or look at specific numbers
that relate
carbon with these properties we found
that there is a lot of variability
and that the quantitative association
between these properties vary a lot
and that the energy characteristics of
the soil
are going to determine our capability to
sequester carbon but
also the impact that carbon will have in
these properties
and sword texture is probably the most
important properties
that control carbon retention capability
and how carbon relates
with with these factors so here we build
using cornell soil health laboratory
data
we just put in a textured triangle
a heat map with showing how carbon
contents are distributed as a function
of texture
and that is something well known for all
of us so we cannot think about carbon
without considering texture
and we know that soils with finer
textures are
the ones that can fix and retain more
carbon
so according to what we were talking
about we might think
that the rest of soil properties like
water retention and infiltration are
going to have similar
patterns as the one we are observing
in carbon however
what all the work in soil health that
harold
and joseph and all the people in cornell
so health lab has done
shows that this is much more complicated
and here we are showing some examples
in the same texture triangles just
plotting other properties like water
retention phosphorus and aggregate
stability
to show that they are not exactly
following the same
pattern that we observe in soil organic
carbon
and we can spend a lot of time
discussing what factors are
controlling these patterns and
how where the samples are coming from
the techniques used to determine
the indicators among others determine
what we are seeing here but today we
just want to
show that this is much more complex that
carbon and texture and there are many
other factors that control soil health
parameters
and that trying to focus only in carbon
to summarize all of them
might be a limitation
and if we try to go a step further are
on relating carbon with
ecosystem services this is going to be
even
more complicated because the ecosystem
services usually rely
in a combination of soil properties
together with climate
and management and other factors
so the increase in yield with increasing
solar organic carbon
is the number one co-benefit mentioned
in
by strike in this context of the carbon
hype
however this is the best
or most comprehensive assessment that we
have
relating carbon and eels nowaday
and we can see that there is a lot of
uncertainty
in this relationship so overall we see
that increasing carbon
increase yields so it's positive
but the uncertainty in this data is
is huge and if we
look into a specific studies
we found that there are some group of
studies showing
very positive and linear relationships
of
carbon and ills some other studies might
show that there is no
any relationship or non-effect
others are showing quadratic or linear
plateau relationships
and even there are some studies showing
that
increasing carbon might generate a
definition
on ill so we don't want you to focus in
the
specific plots but
we know that many factors
explain why all of these results are
correct
but they are showing different range of
carbons they are showing different
climate conditions
management practices if the crop
is fertilizer or not if it's irrigated
the crop the crop type and also a very
important factor that should be
considered
is how the difference in soil organic
carbon
in the soil are generated is it
isn't the same if we increase carbon by
adding a manure
or biochar or changing crop rotation
system
and what other parameters will vary
together with carbon in each one of
those practices
and emily is going to go a little bit
farther in that but
the message is that it is impossible to
understand
how carbon relates with these ecosystem
services without a context
thanks valentina so as as valentina
mentioned
to build solar organic carbon um
various management practices can be used
and therefore
depending on the management practice
different outcomes
will affect the soil health and
ecosystem services
and so we might think about how might
the approach to building soil organic
carbon
impact various co-benefits and are all
management strategies the same
and then as we think of specific
cropping systems
and different locations we also need to
consider
how feasibility and cost variation are
going to play into
strategies to building cell carbon
so here is one example cover crops is a
highly highly used approach to build
soil organic carbon
and this is a meta-analysis looking at
four different climatic regions tropical
arid temperate and snow
and we can see that in all four of these
regions
that cover crops can yes build carbon in
the soil can sequester carbon
however if we look at the orange here
according to this meta-analysis yes
cover crops are valuable
in arid regions however we know in water
limited areas this will have
negative implications on yield for the
primary cash crop
and so these these trade-offs are
complicated and have to be have to be
mentioned
uh secondly if we look at the blue box
here
we have the tropical climates cover
crops used in tropical climates
sequestering the most carbon however
we know there's various implications to
permanence
of that carbon in the soil across
different temperatures and
moisture levels and so again more
nuances that need to be
um introduced and and considered on any
in these systems
and the final the final study here will
bring to your attention
is a meta-analysis or no sorry is that
sorry not a minute
that's a modeling study looking at
european soils
and comparing two different management
practices the first scenario is looking
at the integration of
uh crop residue and a low tillage system
the second is looking at introducing a
nitrogen
fixing cover crop and incorporate it
into the soil as grain manure
so this study was this calculation was
modeled out over 80 years
and in the first scenario we see that
co2 it is a this is a sink
the net ghg flux is a net negative
however we look at the second situation
the carbon from a carbon standpoint
looks
fairly well over the looks great over
the next 80 years
but however if we look and consider the
n2o implications
particularly after
2050 overall the net ghg flux
is isn't it positive um and so and so we
need to think about
this this comes the two points here is
first
sometimes looking at the scenario on a
short term can
can yield positive benefits however
these practices and programs need to be
looked at
at a longer term time point the other
piece the second piece is
if we look at just one piece of the
system such as carbon
focusing on carbon we may
ultimately be missing the bigger picture
such as the net ghd flux
and so this is two things to think about
so finally valentina and i really see
and others see that there
is an opportunity for a research
engagement agenda
within scs and sips we have
key personnel faculty across across
this space that really can can
understand and is working on various
areas within
within this space and has and many of
you have already been
and continue to be deeply engaged at a
national international level
with government and the private sector
and having these conversations
because ultimately there does need to be
a recalibration there's a lot of
overselling being done to stakeholders
and there's an opportunity to
recalibrate those
conversations and essentially embrace
the complexities
around the relationships with soil
organic carbon
and the co-benefits because these
relationships are
complex and if we look at the literature
and and really dive deeply into
individual
co-benefits some are are not fully
proven particularly in certain contexts
environmental contexts
and then finally many of these so carbon
initiatives are
oh we can head back are are focused on
on greenhouse gas sequestration but
ultimately
there is a value in rethinking the
system in placing
other other co-benefits
water quality other soil health metrics
as the primary
benefit and thinking of greenhouse gas
sequestration as a co-benefit so really
reframing the scenario
so finally final reflections
um that valentina and i have come
come to but also would like to bring
some of these questions to the front of
your mind and
as andy mentioned before if you have an
extra 15
20 minutes we really look forward to
hearing any
lingering thoughts or comments on some
of these
points that we mentioned as well as
these questions but
ultimately the current hype is not
embracing the complexities
around around this topic and so the
first question
is what what are we missing in the
system by focusing on a single metric
such as carbon sequestration these
conversations in the public space
are are great but could there be
negative outcomes
if carbon is the only it's the only
focus
uh what is the role that we have as a
scientific community
to include the complexities around this
topic
and then finally at the same time is it
possible to keep this topic
understandable to the general public
without losing the complexities
ultimately this is this is a great time
in a great a great space that these
conversations of soil health
um carbon sequestration through
agriculture
um banks ag based climate solutions is
in the front of the conversation
it's a great time and how can how can we
gear research and our conversations and
engagement
to have have understandable conversation
palatable conversations but still
embracing
the complexity of the topic
so we look forward to handling any
questions you have answering any
questions you have and
more importantly look forward to your
comments after afterwards
so thanks thanks again
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu